Rafi what's up buddy here muted by the
way you got to take that line out of
your mic take it off how's it going what
do you got for me
okay so I had I had a question and it's
a pretty solid question I I think I
handled it very well this is about a
friend of mine a guy a friend of mine
I'm quite I can say I'm quite unplugged
thank God uh so the this is a very close
guy friend of mine I've known him for
many many years and he started dating a
girl maybe two years ago and they've
broken up constantly the craziest part
about this girl is that I hooked up with
her before he knew her and then several
other of our you hooked up with her
before he knew her does he know that he
knows it he knows it yeah okay I told
him before they were dating and he dated
her knowing this which is wild to me but
that's okay
anyhow they they were dating on and off
and he I'm pretty sure she took his
excuse me she took his virginity
he's one he's been you know due to
religion he I think he's the only friend
I've had growing up that state of
version that long
okay so long story short I think the sex
was great and I think that's why she
that's why he stuck around
and I say that from from my own personal
knowledge obviously
and then and I would tell him I was in
the beginning I said hey man listen I I
was shocked when he told me they were
dating honestly and he knew I was
surprised but then he
he went through with it and I said hey
man listen you're my boy you know I
support you and as time went on I
noticed that she was pretty
disrespectful to him be disrespectful in
public she's like that she's very uh
very out there she's very much an
extrovert but she's kind of attention
seeking so
at the end I confronted him and I said
hey man listen I I support whatever
makes you happy I don't think this is
the girl for you and then all of her
other friends came forward and said the
same thing now he says he broke up with
her but he keeps going back for the sex
and then she kind of reels him in
what would you say that I haven't told
him in terms of
dude you just you got to move on how old
is he he is my age he's 29 just turned
29. he was he was a virgin until he was
29. he was no I think he was a virgin
until maybe he was 28 he was doing he's
a good looking guy that's the funny he's
not one of these weebie dudes I'm really
I'm not friends with people like that
okay because of religion he is he's a
religious guy religious Jewish to be
clear yeah and it's wild to me because
I'm very much not
well look man I mean you know the guys
first he never
he never really knows what to do after
that you know if it doesn't work out
right and
I'm just you know I'm just trying to
think back because that was a long time
ago right that's that's like
she's she's pretty sticky like even if
she's crazy you know she's pretty sticky
like you're gonna have a hard time
forgetting about her you're gonna have a
hard time moving on from her I'm
guessing that she's just sort of like
bang them dated him sort of thing and
then she dumped him you know what it is
Rich and it's funny because I just I
wanted to get your perspective but
she she's attracted to him physically
but he can't lead her he also he lives
with his parents of course
um and she's missing that component
which is funny because
I've always given that energy to her but
I would never date I would never date a
girl like that especially I would never
date a girl that hooks up with one of my
friends absolutely not yeah well look
man that's that's a deal breaker right
off the bat you shouldn't be getting
serious with a chick that was hooking up
with one of your friends that's
that's one of the first areas that he's
making a major mistake in which he has
to re recalibrate and square his head
away out it's like dude like I was just
there and now you're in there you see
like how that's strange like does that
not compute for you my friend like
there's eight billion people on the
planet half of them are women they don't
think you can find somebody else
right yeah what's her story though right
I mean if she's hooking up with you that
means that she's hooking up with other
guys too right oh this girl is far from
innocent dude this girl is that's what
was so mind-boggling to me and I by the
way after like when you say far from
innocent like are we talking The Village
bicycle here
back in high school she was a bit of a
bit of a you know she she
yeah dude it was mind-blowing to me I
introduced him to a lot of this content
because I said I I quite frankly I've
been around the block a little bit yeah
a lot of it so I've gained a lot of this
knowledge but I I love your content roll
those content uh because I I
reassuring all of this to me is just
it's been very helpful so I've I've
helped him a lot I said dude the truth
the fact of the matter is you don't have
enough experience you need to get out
there more you need to get laid more and
then you won't she won't be as special
to you you realize that at the end of
the day she wasn't what you thought she
was and once you get some more ass uh
you will have a much easier time moving
on is he um is he hardcore like um
religious Jew
he's the Moroccan Jewish origin so when
they're released they aren't he's not a
prude but you know he's got his dick
sucked over the years but he's okay you
know he the Virgin thing was important
they they can be very strict about
certain things so why doesn't he apply
those standards to his you know the
woman that he's gonna invite into his
life right like he's let this low
caliber
garden tool into his life that's spent
her high school years running around and
even doing it in her 20s how old is she
she's a little older than him now what
is she 30 so she's even older than him
which is another red flag oh dude full
of red flags it's it's he just just you
know what give him give him my chapter
on red flags you can just print up a PDF
you just opt into the email list and
print it up just give him that chapter
on red flags and just say here read this
and you tell me how many of these you
want to start ticking off that you know
she's got and you know what my friend
you can you know you can chase her you
can get married to her you can make her
your girlfriend you can put a bunch of
babies in it which I will stop dude I
will literally stop the wedding well
well the point that I'm getting at is he
needs to arrive at that himself you
can't tell him bro she's no good for you
right you need like guys need to arrive
at this is not a good decision and I am
going to ruin my life himself and the
red flag chapter is essentially written
in such a way that anybody can get it
that's got half a brain in their head
where it's like obvious have you read my
book
I I haven't I haven't I want to say I
have I want to say I know that's cool
not everybody reads it um
a lot of your videos yeah so so the
ticker's on the bottom guys if you're
new to the channel go to entrepreneurs
and cars.com forward slash red Dash
Flags you can download the chapter for
free you don't even have to buy the book
um just download it for him Rafi give it
to him and I would say look go through
this and you tell me how many of the red
flags she's got you can get married to
this woman you can put babies in or you
can make your girlfriend if you want but
your life will be unnecessarily
complicated
right if that's what you want if you
want to complicate your life
unnecessarily if you want to invite
crazy into it that's cool we probably
ain't going to be hanging out that much
though
that's the way that I would handle it
right because honestly dude why do you
want a a close friend an idiot that's
gullible persuadable and stupid that is
going to make bad choices because at the
end of the day if he's your boy and
you're hanging out and you're doing
stuff he's going to invite chaos into
your life as well too
at some point you see what I'm saying
that's valid I'm very cognizant of that
it's
like I know that that's hard for guys to
hear you know when I say you need to be
fastidious with the people that you
spend time with but you do right like
you have to have boundaries and it's not
just boundaries and dating you know with
women or like whatever it happens to be
but you have to have boundaries with
friendships as well too the people that
you're going to do business with the
people that you're going to roll with
the circles that you're going to travel
in right you have to set some standards
you know you want to get great results
out of life raise your standards and
that's basically what you're telling
your friend to do is raise your
standards right like don't invite
[__] into your life
yeah 100 I think he's I think he's
finally I think he's fine I'm gonna give
him the benefit benefit of the doubt I
think he's finally coming to terms with
it he said they're done I mean listen
that'll that's on him he's I live in
Florida he lives in New York now so I
don't see him very often uh moved I grew
up in New York I moved here four years
ago so I I don't see him very often but
uh I've been very straight with him
about it I've been very Frank with him
he's an adult he has to decide exactly
but uh I did want to ask now that we're
we're on the live I host a podcast
myself
um it may not be the best time but I
just was wondering if we could if we
could connect I've had Adam Rollo
Michael thirteen a couple of other guys
shoot me a email it's on the about tab
of the YouTube channel and you know just
send me a link to the um podcast and uh
dates that you're available and I'll uh
I'll take a look at it okay awesome much
appreciated thanks all right thanks man
yep I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out